alright Congressman Bob Goodlatte this
weekend calling on the former CIA chief
John Brennan to testify to Congress on
his role in this Russia which on hoax
here with reaction to Judicial Watch
president tom Fitton who deserves a big
pat on the back tonight former federal
prosecutor Andy McCarthy let's go to
that particular point and get your
reaction and more importantly just get
your general reaction of what we learned
today
well Oh Saturday night the Saturday
night dump you know look on the on the
security clearances I think anybody who
abuses their security clearance whether
it's to politicize intelligence or to
leak intelligence if they find out that
you did that you should get your clear
inject I don't like seeing the the
debate about it get politicized it's too
late they politicize well I did Hillary
let's go to the beginning Hillary
violate the Espionage Act I think she
did yes Minh she deleted and bleach pit
and beat up her devices that obstruction
after it was subpoenaed yeah the the
documents were the stuff was under
congressional turn top FBI officials
turn on Trump in a way that is
unprecedented and used their power
against an opposition party candidate to
stop him with an insurance policy I
think they weaponized the intelligence
and the law enforcement apparatus of the
government throughout the the Obama
administration but they certainly the
court judges not once but four times
yeah I mean they they well first of all
they didn't with respect to the dossier
it was not corroborated and when they
said it was verified in that well their
own policies demanded their own policies
they're not supposed to you then well
yes the law demands that you provide
accurate information to a court it
doesn't require that it be verified and
corroborated but their procedures
Rottweilers and Stein said that if not
they're gonna be consequences I played
that tonight well let's see if there are
not holding my breath go through the
same list of questions your mind to
start with Hillary end up with lying to
the FISA Court judges four times with
Russian
paid for by an opposition party okay you
know it doesn't it doesn't take a lot to
yank a security clearance the deep
states been playing a security clearance
game with the Trump administration since
its come into office denying pulling
punishing those who are deemed too close
to Trump by pulling security clearances
are delaying them but when it comes to
Comey and mccabe it's a no-brainer both
were fired from Ron duck Brennan Yates I
would hate sin this by the way clapper
what i clappers accused of lying quite
credibly and the basis for pulling a
security clearance is credible
derogatory information and it's hard to
say that there's no credible derogatory
information you got clapper who it kind
of admits the lying
you have Brennan who was accused in a
book of leaking purposely the DA say to
Harry Reid with the hopes of getting
gets leaked out that's all true media
that's also telling a politician about
something that was Russian lies bought
and paid for the CIA director is
spreading Russian lies as CIA director
to sealers and Susan Rice had a number
of explanations contradictory
explanations about her involvement and
unmasking
you know again I was unmasked and
surveilled and if he did do it find
anybody for I find out did this
illegally I will sue them and hire the
best legal team including Andy on the
planet to go after them alright let me
go back to you wasn't this all about
Russian lies paid for disseminated
propagated lying to courts wasn't this
all about lying to the American people
with Russian lies of all things I think
it was about pushing the envelope as far
as you could could push it being too
nice so I'm saying for the politics of
the election and I think they did it
because number one the FISA stuff is
classified and number two they were sure
Hillary was going to win and no one was
ever going to be any of the wiser but
did they if you
like to a court where would I be now we
should be in jail probably me and Jeff I
if I just want to put I destroyed
subpoenaed information what would happen
to me the normal person that does this
gets prosecuted you know it quickly is
there any doubt is there any doubt that
this dot this whole FISA Court had a
platoon both